Oh house Cumbres my name is Pierre oh
that's a good one let's keep playing
heart of darkness what kill what even
killed me I can't see I'm gonna go down
here they're gonna duck here oh it kills
me anyway oh that's funny that's how I
became a shoe again I became a shoe
again I became a shoe again I am a shoe
and I got [ __ ] in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey I did it look at that oh ok alright
ok everything everything is going as
planned
I became a pancake that's hysterical and
another one let's go here baby
ok what do I owe God it's gonna kill me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
awesome
it's not gonna stop it maybe haha
suck my dick haha nailed it
yeah alright what do we do now
what does that do are we pull down this
okay come at me bro [ __ ] dare you bro
we're supposed to bring this over here
maybe that doesn't work
okay we're we're bringing it back baby
alright I'm gonna shoot it here that
makes sense let's do that oh my god
die and burn in hell and [ __ ]
is that Han Solo carbonite in the
background the more you resisted more I
will [ __ ] you that sounded horrible I'm
so sorry oh my god oh my god oh my hey
y'all get that get off me
[ __ ] all of y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] all of
y'all oh yeah keep dodging I'm the
[ __ ] Hitler of these people what do I
do now what the [ __ ] do I go man here we
go
okay nice Oh God be gentle with me
ladies
be gentle I was given one but holding my
days come here Lord
oh god I God oh my god I can't believe I
didn't die okay I know what we're doing
and now we shoot it why did I oh that is
actually what okay I knew that of course
of course I am a genius my name is
PewDiePie I'm the smartest [ __ ]
alive
[ __ ] I miss mother [ __ ] yes the
goo the green goo of course
what am i a dolphin
and then they [ __ ] okay okay we're
back up here now how about you guys
[ __ ] help for once all right
how about you stop drinking beer all
right how about you stop drinking beer
and get a job other helping now okay
maybe they listen finally I'm tired of
this [ __ ] all of y'all can't [ __ ] with
this that's right
that's right [ __ ] burning hell
alright what do I go now you get it gals
gonna help me help me thanks ah ah oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] me charger
that one had boobs
are they all the same gender are they
all her madera Deitz her deaf her deaf
whatever maybe they're like snails they
[ __ ] through their necks don't ask me
how I know that maybe that's why they
call amigos because they all [ __ ] each
other like bros um that was overthinking
with PewDiePie in sexual okay all right
well we're here now I'm just gonna go
hey how's it going I'm just gonna go
this way and I'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] all
of y'all in the [ __ ] dick and there
it is I became a shoe look at that also
handle vector my off at home I jumped oh
is that possible and that's how it's
done ladies in Bros that's how it's done
everyone is dead come go and come lay in
my bed and now we're gonna go this way I
got all quiet now without these [ __ ]
what was that
I'm sure it was nothing let's go can we
shoot this that's cool that's [ __ ]
cool man that's [ __ ] cool that's
[ __ ] cool man
that's [ __ ] cool it's a robot dog
it's going to come back in together
isn't it
okay I have to finish it oh my god
that's creepy too three heavy shots to
kill it [ __ ] house
alright well [ __ ] me then what do I do
don't kill me hey guys how's it going
hey guys how's it going hey guys how's
it going
don't hurt me I'm Swedish let go of me
you slimy beasts Let Go me you're
disgusting pieces of trash oh my god how
am i alive
oh my god with Jenna press this is so
intense
huh okay well then let's continue this
amazing journey that we have together
hey guys wouldn't you die there you go
you're dead now you're dead you're piece
of trash you're more than okay I'll add
them all out I let them all out I let
them all out but then how about that
that's what we wanted to do wasn't it
hey guys how you doing
[ __ ] off what is it what the [ __ ] is
this look how many enemies there I in
this game what did they just live down
there to be [ __ ] in case someone
happens to come down that's it that's it
baby this is disgusting look at this
disgusting I am disgusted what am I
doing here hey oh god no no no oh that's
my bad you won't bug to me you got
[ __ ] mice hey you want some of this oh
my god that nearly hit me guys hey don't
jump hey who taught you guys how to jump
oh my god teach me how to jump
[ __ ] hell they [ __ ] did a [ __ ]
flower man thing that though that's
awesome man guys be gentle
hey guys chill man cool it stop jumping
they [ __ ] duplicate this is
ridiculous
oh my god yes one more yes one more no
skills is what that's [ __ ] cold [ __ ]
off oh they just keep multiplying they
just keep multiplying they just keep
multiplying please die oh god please
kill it gallon gallon gallon
one more sh oh oh
[ __ ] what happens
Oh awesome awesome that's hilarious
that's [ __ ] funny that hahaha oh
that's funny that's [ __ ] funny man
that's so [ __ ] hilarious man I'm
laughing cool here we go
yeah oh [ __ ] that was [ __ ] close oh
my god what is the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
Lord Jesus Christ man anyone else no no
no no no no no no no god damn this game
forbid this game don't ever play this
game cuz this game will play yourself
what happens down here
I don't know possibly more death yes I
think so
well that's too bad because you're not
gonna [ __ ] me are you just go down
[ __ ] you'll jump in any [ __ ]
direction but down I'm gonna go in this
cave now guess not right what do I do
play the drums punch the net ball what
do I do I was supposed to punch nickel
that's [ __ ] disgusting by the way
look at that alright so now we can't
climb there anymore but we can go into
cave no we can we actually can't go in
the game I don't I don't know why I keep
thinking I can go in the cave now we can
claim them the rocks instead of the
titties is that it yeah it is but that's
not what we're going to do in life
oh that's hilarious you're so [ __ ]
funny aren't you
Josh cow Josh Dow God - go just go just
boy that's what happens [ __ ] that's
what [ __ ] happens [ __ ] pieces mmm
this is ridiculous
he came from behind my god just stop
just stop just stop just stop just stop
what a cute white can I not go in here
what's the [ __ ] point of life what's
the [ __ ] point of life do I gotta
press the nipple again is that it we got
to go back again oh god oh my god oh my
god I [ __ ] thought we would just go
back
silly silly me silly me thinking this
would just be an ordinary good old going
back to
I swear to God if this last one [ __ ]
kills me I will [ __ ] I will end it
all
yes skills skills from the hills that
kills these guns oh yeah [ __ ] are you
kidding me and I don't want the world to
see me oh my god Becky look at her butt
suck my ass
suck my ass we did Oh a demon just came
out I think we have to go here now we go
here it's really cool level design I
gotta know I can't even [ __ ] go there
take it back hey guys how's it going
down here did we press all the nipples
yet I I didn't see this but we can climb
here then let's drop down here let's
kill all these [ __ ]
and that's how it's done ladies and bros
suck my ass love you oh my God look it's
Jessica Alba I don't know why I went
with Jessica Alba
I hate them and I hate you know what
more than anything I just hate the
[ __ ] choose men shoot near Luther so
but it's a job last for a desk of also
job last war yeah now it's your turn to
die now yeah I want to thank my mom and
more than anything I want to thank Edgar
for being such a supportive sport we did
it I don't believe it I don't believe it
hi guys sweet sweet euphoria sweet
euphoria I am going down here oh my god
oh my god oh my god it continues at
[ __ ] continues
mm oh cool what Carol I see our stuff
but oh my god so they go down to kill oh
my god I did it oh my god what are we
doing it what do we do now do we do we
okay they they just okay I'm just gonna
go no what do I do
I go down I can't jump oh god oh my god
okay so it changes oh my god
[ __ ] hell weird it oh my god I didn't
touch it
there it is thank you oh that sounds
great they couldn't see it [ __ ] if
they got it see you there oh why did I
forget about a nipple did I forget about
a nipple I forgot about a nipple didn't
I oh god oh god oh god kill me God
please take my flesh and oh God
I forgot about what I forgot about a
nipple I forgot about this one it's
[ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ] not true
[ __ ] kill me this game is horrible
it's not even [ __ ] funny anymore Oh
if this nipple doesn't flip
I will kill then oh god oh god it's this
[ __ ] [ __ ] ago yeah you go please
work please work
hi that's funny that's so funny ha ha ha
ha
oh boy my god I wasn't even recording my
[ __ ] webcam I just realized oh my god
that's [ __ ] insane
great great sorry guys I just realized
that's awesome wait I'm not dead what
the [ __ ]
oh my god what's that supposed to happen
okay hey hey this is me this is how I
look like you'll see one real nice
display through is a [ __ ] mess hey
I'm glad to do that
[ __ ] me daddy hey buddy how you doing
all right we're in prison now all right
there's a coconut over there oh cool
that actually worked hey guess what
you're the worst prison guard of all
time I wonder how I knew there was a
coconut there surely he sees what's
going on right now die in hell
[ __ ]
well that was fun let's do that again
all right well wits keys out so now we
gotta think of something I should
probably take this away hey doesn't
climb up the [ __ ] idiot
oh boy this is fun oh yeah no it was fun
it was it was hilarious well this is
awkward
can I kill him
that's [ __ ] weird man
Aloha the sound effects from him sounds
like he's in latex okay what are we oh
great Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go yes don't
kill me thank you game I can't believe
this I'm loosing my [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God
so sick of these [ __ ] yes got'em
what now no no
I [ __ ] jumped
oh my god how am i alive I think I know
what I need to do and it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
go to the left [ __ ]
y'all a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] why
don't they go hi guys
cool well I'm glad we did that really
really okay well I'm glad we did it my
way
disgusting [ __ ] thing man I want to
suck its nose
what a dick I mean I don't have the
power anymore oh no we don't have the
power anymore
awesome I thought this game was too easy
so yeah the [ __ ] hell
this game is brutal oh great oh great
hey I was just about to go anyway Oh
awesome and I can't run there oh my god
Jesus [ __ ] me oh my god
calm down everyone
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go oh my god oh my god
oh my god what does that do and we go
back a suppose what the [ __ ] this game
is ridiculous this game is ridiculous
ridiculous this game is redic go up ah
so fun the every [ __ ] time we did the
sound effects huh
we did the [ __ ] sound effects hey
will you not kill me
thanks let's try not diet the easiest
[ __ ] part this time thanks I'm gonna
take a break I had a [ __ ] die I'm
dying okay well I took a little break
and back and now we're gonna play and
it's gonna be great
hello fabric oh great and then we go
down here that's it that's it baby
god the noises they make are so annoying
oh he's coming he's coming he's got a
great angle on my popper press the
button and now we come on Matt me me bro
go down back in it come on Britt in to
win it we're in it to win it we're in it
to win it
come on oh yeah boy we're not in Kansas
anymore come on boy hey ho that's how
it's done
did I do it yeah I did it
ha no we didn't do it oh god no no no
what are you doing man keep running ah
go come on buddy
yeah yeah oh it's the sexy piece again
and they didn't even they don't even
chew a little bit what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was not funny we're inside the
belly [ __ ] do I do now oh my god oh my
god we have the eight the gun he ain't
the gun Oh guess who's back I'm gonna
kill every single one army may have sped
a little bit there anyone else want some
you got him see you up there
you're all dead to me you're all dead to
me oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no get away
goddamn it how many [ __ ] are that get
up get off my car how many [ __ ] are
there [ __ ] off
god damn it yeah I hate them oh my god
just dies just a just a stop playing
you're not among you're not a [ __ ]
flying [ __ ] okay I'm just gonna go
I'm the oh there you go fell for that
old tree oh my god what the [ __ ] is this
game never ends does it
I was in the [ __ ] air great there's
more of them now
yes got'em my my my marriage I'm so glad
we got the gun back I'm so [ __ ]
pumped oh god it never ends well you're
gonna shoot at me
I face the consequence what the [ __ ] do
I do now
come on damn it
come on yes got'em ok can we go back now
no which one did I go on my even
supposed to be here there it is oh my
god oh my god
give me a [ __ ] break Oh God give me a
[ __ ] break
aah I hate you
god I hate you all right what do we do
with this [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god
can you cool it [ __ ] cool it man
what a [ __ ] a it's the other one's
dead
oh god I'm shooting his heel ah I think
I got one oh my god you know what keep
no there's someone there damnit I have
to kill them sneaky [ __ ] developers
they were so [ __ ] sneaky oh my god
[ __ ] me [ __ ] off all of y'all and that's
how it's done did we do it I think we
done diddly dazzle day
well I be on my way now thank you very
much oh well like we're gonna have a
little talk aren't we that's right let
me suck your nose finally
I don't know where you let's go get
walkies really listen big deal beautiful
look join the pieces of the meeting
together
god damn he's so nice
his nose just came that's [ __ ]
awesome alright will you stay here but
well while I do all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you hey I found one alright what do I do
with it I give it back to him now you
want you want some of this you want some
of this yeah I'll give it to you what if
I was going to give it to you okay I
think I I think that sound confirms that
I did it thanks for pointing at me
[ __ ] okay so now we're gonna go here
and I'm sure there's not going to be a
long time before something kills me
thank you video game you can't even
[ __ ] see them look how dark they are
take them
that's right I know your tricks now game
you can't [ __ ] trick me anymore oh
god it's gonna be bad isn't it sneaky
[ __ ] stop it all right how about this
I'm clearly shooting them I can't go
there please don't kill me thank you
thank you for that maybe we're just
gonna be fast
that's it all right now what I think I
did something [ __ ] that sounded good
that sounded great let's look what we
did
maybe we did something on this screen I
don't know no we did not
oh wait I can crawl on that okay I got
it don't worry about it breasts I know
in 100 percent what I'm doing I'm by 100
percent I mean 0% math is weird like
that okay is it time
okay well or we can just do that as
opposed okay what the [ __ ] are those
things in the background this game is so
creepy watch watch watch the game kill
me oh it's decided to spare me thank you
game
Oh sneaky [ __ ] Oh God yeah I'm not gonna
take the risk or is it just up okay hey
how about that hey another stone okay so
now we got to push it back like a
football oh this is bad okay it's gonna
fall down there I'm not gonna go down
there I'm gonna go down this way
hey puzzles how about that okay so now
we need to do this
maybe we need to shoot it yes genius
Pierce strikes again it's really cool I
missed kind of the puzzle parts this
game gets so [ __ ] intense sometimes
okay and now we just put it push it all
the way back down lovely that's this
just a lot of fun let's do this again
sometime video game hey I'm pushing a
ball with my head through a really tight
corridor this is my how did my life end
up here I don't know we're pushing it
down there seems like a bad idea but
[ __ ] it I don't think we have much of it
yeah that's it we did it yay another
football for the family hey come on come
on buddy hey buddy come on there it is
don't be shine a little Bali I love you
Bali you're my best friend you're out
call your green barley green Bali Bali
boom oh he wants more doesn't he what a
greedy little [ __ ] isn't he stopped
pointing what a [ __ ] dick [ __ ] Oh
ah jeez
what do you do I hear like squeaky latex
sounds what kind of perverted [ __ ] is
this guy doing hey man then they we
didn't we have a deal no why is there
piece missing like what do you want
admitted what are you my minute you keep
pointing the sound he makes it's the
[ __ ] worse whoever designed that guy
is a [ __ ] twisted fella I bet they
were like we're gonna sell a ton of a
plushies a ton of latex plushies it's
gotta be great kids love it just love
giant knows these people they love it I
love it I'm sorry I love it I want one
and I have one in my bar Danko right now
okay there it is
gonna I can go further up I guess I
don't really know which way nailed it
oh okay so I think I see it the guys
moving down there isn't he and he
controls the switches could you move
come on come on what are you doing man
what the [ __ ] was that oh my god
oh my god they [ __ ] control sometimes
I swear to god it's cuz I have this
controller and it's clearly not meant
for it if you play like press like
accidentally diagonally death oh my god
I [ __ ] [ __ ] wasn't even that [ __ ]
hard like come on
Oh God Oh God [ __ ] that awesome hey guys
don't kill me
thank you Hey look at those skills Hey
look at his skills
oh my god I think I actually did it
[ __ ] hell holy che this game is
awesome I gotta say it's pretty [ __ ]
cool man
do I need them perhaps oh my god
irenna suck my ass [ __ ] I don't know
what this does but I did it hey another
ball hey I got Kim you're gonna do that
again oh you are okay [ __ ] okay I'm
just gonna shoot the ball then hey the
ball has a little elevator that's cute
now I think I gotta press this button to
do this but I'm not sure let's try it
Hey look at that it worked out hey never
mind
hahaha hey elevator number two how about
that how about that alright and now we
do the same thing again and video games
I think I was supposed to do that but
I'm not entirely sure okay all right we
got to do this [ __ ] again
there it is [ __ ] you Oh God don't die
okay we're fine where did the ball go
there where's the ball guys oh it's
there how to [ __ ] away okay we got to
kill these [ __ ] it's my ball no come
on come on hit the [ __ ] potatoes
oh no don't hit the potatoes and now
there's more of them that's great
hit the potatoes hit the damn potatoes
oh my god thank you can you keep jumping
in hell [ __ ] hit the potatoes there it
is hey low blow bully food with a pata
pata it's interesting how small they are
here but later they just became huge
just like my this guys are gonna be
tricky
I shouldn't be tricky actually I'll just
shoot it across [ __ ] you oh great nice
one dude [ __ ] you god damn it ball don't
squeeze me thank you hey we did it one
more ball one more ball we gonna
celebrate celebrate and dance so free oh
my god I'm so sick of balls actually
that was a really fun puzzle I really
enjoy the puzzle cards a lot more than
the platforming ones because god damnit
do I suck at platforming skills there's
anything I learned from this the whole
experience that is what I've learned my
god okay well here we are also that this
boy has a twisted [ __ ] imagination
how about that [ __ ] came up with Jar
Jar Binks like kind of [ __ ] hellish
mind you have to have to come up with
that [ __ ]
alright here we go here's the last ball
[ __ ] then [ __ ] what that sounds you got
to rub it with your deck yes bits
missing there is some tiny bit missing
there it is on the bridge we have to
have it it's easy like the inspiration
for Gollum in Lord of the Rings so now
he's pointing this way dude you spent
all this time waiting for me alright you
spent all this time and you can't even
[ __ ] like it will find a lot
goddamnit you know what can I go in here
it's just telling me I should go here
alright that's all like oh god they
respawn okay that's uh oh my god oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes yes oh that is a
nice looking dog
hey don't kick Edgar holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
doggy move you go now where is he let's
see moisturize it looks so soft well
then all right bro I hope you enjoyed
yet another part there's another one
waiting for you what are you doing I'll
wait go ahead and leave like and
subscribe and I'll see you Bros in the
next video yeah shake it